the more peaceful
protests happen before dark and the
violence really ramps up after dark
so you know there is there is the
possibility that someone wandering in at
one time or the other would actually not
be aware of the other
on the other hand at this point given
what we know is happening
every single night in portland every
single night after dark into
into the wee hours you know this time of
year it gets dark pretty late um
how how could you be that confused
about this being a totally honorable and
peaceful protest
it's it can't be it can't be at this
point so i think the at this point is
crucial and i i was um talking to eric
last night and
thinking about some things and we were
going back through some of the prior
protests that have occurred especially
in this part of the world
and i was thinking in particular about
occupy
and initially you and i were very uh
enthusiastic about occupy because it
seemed like finally this was something
new and different that was protesting
things that needed to be protested like
the tarp program too big to fail the uh
obvious catastrophe of credit default
swaps and
leveraging and all of this and
the thing was there was the sense that
we hadn't seen
anything progressive in
decades maybe at all in our lifetime and
suddenly there was motion where
suddenly we were we were protesting the
things that needed protesting
and the problem is inside it then became
clear that it went from a protest
against
thing it was a coherent protest to an
anarchist protest
and i tried to persuade i mean i wrote a
couple of articles in fact
trying to persuade them that anarchism
was an answer to nothing and that they
needed to get back on track which of
course didn't work
but my point is there are those who are
just simply waiting for anything that
doesn't look like what they've
experienced and to the extent
that the antifa riots
are portraying themselves as progressive
there are a lot of people who aren't
paying close attention who think okay
finally
right we're in the streets you know
protesting for the right thing
when in fact they're protesting for the
wrong thing they're protesting for
the uninvention of all of the uh the
liberal
principles on which the nation was
founded and to which we were
headed so well and you and you saw more
than i did
even in occupy as as you watched it
unravel from the inside
uh a specific rejection of the idea of
leadership
right a specific rejection of the idea
that
individuals should be in position
of of leadership or able to
not necessarily dictate but have the
role of being able to help run help
facilitate
uh situations and groups of people such
that decisions could be made
the idea of hierarchy was itself
anathema
right and so this this struck both of us
as delusional
right it it is it is this utopian vision
that has
no chance of actually happening we can
do better we can certainly do better
than what evolution has handed us
and uh we have been we have lived in
much more hierarchical ways in the past
with much more rigid roles
around lots of things like race and like
sex than we need to
but the idea that hierarchy is itself um
either uh we are either capable of
getting rid of it
or it is worthy of of being gotten rid
of
both of those ideas are are batshit
crazy
yeah that makes no sense at all and it
tells you right there
that the movement has no chance of
success
in the way that it's claiming it wants
success
and also one of the ways that it works
tactically
is it makes it very much harder to chase
it down
because because who do you go after and
you know one person says
all cops are bastards and another person
says defund the police another one says
abolish the police another one says
we don't want any policing at all and
you go back to the first one they said
well
i never said that's not my position and
i'm at tifa and you know maybe they
aren't
you know maybe they're they're playing
at it and so the lack of leadership is
not only
uh insane if you try to scale that up at
a societal level but it is actually
also incredibly effective at a tactical
level with regard to street level riots
yeah it runs through your fingers as you
try to pin down what it is that we're
even talking about
so i was asked on twitter um this guy
begins by saying a
big fan love what you guys are doing um
but i do want to ask you
do you think that living in portland
this is a quote from him do you think
that living in portland which seems like
ground zero for the woke volusion
is coloring y'all's hopes and fears for
the future for example i live in a small
town in virginia
we thank god haven't had 50 nights of
rioting in a row
curious if you think that the northwest
violence will inevitably spread virally
throughout the country or if it's a big
city phenomenon
and you know my one of my first
responses to that and we should talk
about it is
as we've been saying for decades but
publicly since evergreen blew up what
happens on campus doesn't stay on campus
guys
it it was never going to and so this is
a direct
a direct result of what's been going on
on campus
and the point of this is that it's going
to spread and it is spreading and we see
the media captured and uh
you know arts organizations increasingly
captured in higher ed
and k-12 schools and increasingly the
courts and
you know it's capture one by one by one
so
it is it is quite possible that our lens
is
clouded that we we are seeing this on
the other hand
actually you know we live in a part of
portland where we don't have to run into
this at all
we don't we don't see it uh unless we
choose to to go to it and
figure out what we can see with our own
eyes as opposed to what's been filtered
by other people
so um you know that's that's also a
filter that people are saying oh my god
are you you're important are you safe
yeah you know it's it's a it's a very
it's a few
very limited very minor very horrifying
very at risk of becoming giant uh
sets of movements that are happening in
both downtown and
eastern portland yeah um
i think you know we should probably at
some point
catalog the misunderstandings that we
think people were talking to
are having one of them is that this is
about
symbolic stuff this is very definitely
about
power over material things ultimately
this results in a
transfer of material things through
mechanisms
that are not
legitimate but nonetheless the
horizontal nature of this whole movement
means that it is now infused in every
place that can make a judgment
and so you know hiring firing
the courts every place that can make a
judgment there is now an expectation
that these things will go
in a particular direction yep and you
know it can't work it's a very
short-term strategy but will it
ultimately
um get to you it will get to you and you
know who's telling you that
the people who said that it was going to
escape you know
the university system back whenever
green was
the you know the type specimen so
i i think it's just certain that if
something does not turn the tide
that this will ultimately wash over
everything and it will of course render
the us
a feeble power which will create a power
vacuum
and then we'll find out what dynamics
are really going to govern our lives